All right, now, why am I talking about
UFOs? I don't know if you've been
following the media.
I don't know if you've been following
the media.
They had congressional meetings. It is
now
admitted and it's now public knowledge.
Pay attention, guys. Class has begun.
Meaning no side talk, no distractions.
Ask Holy Spirit to help you stay
attentive as he uses me to bless you,
okay?
I don't know if you know, in America,
last week they've had congregation
congre
congressional, please Holy Spirit, save
me. And do not allow us to betray or
deny or blaspheme our God and say Lord
Jesus said, but love the Lord Jesus
Christ, the Father's heart even unto
death. Rebuke Satan in our flesh.
They've had congressional hearings
where
people are now being interviewed and
admitting the government
knows about UFOs and they actually have
evidence for aliens because they've
contacted them, they've interacted with
them, as well as
unidentified flying objects. The
congregation congressional hearings
are now all over the news.
What they call whistleblowers
who have government positions or contact
with government officials being
interviewed and admitting, yes, it's a
fact, UFOs are real, aliens exist. And
now they're public about it.
Not only are they public about it, but
even on Vlad TV, I'm going to show you,
one of the leading UFO experts who has
claimed to have contacted UFOs and has
been in contact with people who
contacted UFOs or UFOs contacted them
and government officials, he's being
interviewed.
I'm going to show you some clips. I
can't play them thoroughly. Why? Because
I'm going to get flagged for copyright.
But let me tell you what this means.
In fact, this person that I'm going to
play a few minutes of, he acknowledges
UFOs have always always been around. And
he says that you'll find ancient texts
and you'll find inscriptions in walls,
even in India,
where they depict depict what we call
UFOs. In other words, here's more
confirmation for what I've been telling
you and others more knowledgeable than
me, more qualified than me.
Others who've been telling you the
ancient gods are the aliens.
Now, why is that important? Please pay
attention. I'm going to play a few
clips. Now, they're being public.
They're not hiding it anymore. And I'm
going to tell you why that's
significant, and I'm going to tell you
what I think it means. Now, I'm not a
prophet.
I'm not saying thus saith the Lord. I'm
human. But, I'm observing what's
happening, and I'm going to tell you
what I think this means, and may God
save me from error and falsehood.
You can't deny UFOs exist.
It's now the media is now confirming.
Can you imagine it's gotten to the level
they now have congressional hearings,
where the people are being interviewed
saying, "Yes, UFOs exist. Aliens exist.
We've been in contact with them, and the
government knows, and there are
documents affirming it."
Have you been watching the news, you
guys in America? It's been all over the
news. They've been announcing it to the
point that even TYT, this wicked radical
liberal anti-Christian group, may the
Lord Jesus teach them to fear the Lord
and silence them.
They're even acknowledging, "Yeah, the
evidence seems to be pointing they're
aliens." And they say, "Yeah, we believe
aliens exist."
I'm going to show you some clips. Okay?
Now, this one expert who wasn't
interviewed, but he was on Vlad TV,
who's done documentaries, he's
interviewed government officials who've
gone public and private, and produced
data from even government footage and
others. He says, "Yeah, aliens exist. We
made contact with them. They made
contact with us. They They're real." The
cat is out of the bag, folks.
Aliens are real, but they're also saying
the ancient gods were the aliens. What
they called gods and goddesses were
aliens. You know why that's important?
Because according to your Bible,
if you read the Greek version of Psalm
96:5, which in the Greek is Psalm 95:5,
Psalm 95 verse 5 in the Greek, it says,
"And the gods of the nations are
demons."
And if you read Deuteronomy 32:16-17,
read Deuteronomy 32:16-17,
okay?
And you read Psalm 106:36-37,
and if you read 1 Corinthians 10:19-22,
you're told that the Gentiles
worship demons.
Their gods and goddesses are Satan and
demons appearing as gods and goddesses,
and today they're appealing appearing as
aliens.
I just answered, Heaven free. Are you
listening?
They're admitting to you the gods and
goddesses,
the people who saw these objects and
drew on walls or in books the objects,
what we'd call UFOs, those are the same
beings appearing today, and they called
those beings gods and goddesses, and the
Bible says they're demons. They're
Satan. They're not extraterrestrial.
They're demons, and now the government's
admitting they're appearing and they
exist.
Now, I'm going to tell you what I think
that means,
okay? But let me show you on this
computer some of the I can't play all of
it
because I'm going to get flagged, okay?
Okay?
Pay attention.
Folks, your government is now admitting
they're real.
They're now public about it. They're
admitting it's real. Guys, it's real.
Stop this nonsense of being skeptical.
Which means these demons are about to
appear.
Now, what does that mean?
Let me tell you what it means.
Demons are about to appear.
When it gets to this level
of publicity
and acknowledgement, that means the
demons
will appear sooner than later. They're
going to show themselves to the world.
And that means our Lord Jesus is at
hand.
It's what I'm trying to show you.
That means the Lord Jesus is at hand.
Now, I'm not saying thus saith the Lord.
I'm not a prophet.
I may be mistaken.
I'm just sharing you my observation. May
the Lord Jesus perfect me from mistakes
and save me from error, save you from
error, and save us from sin to walk
worthy of the Lord Jesus Christ.
Okay?
Let me show you. I'm going to show you
my playlist.
It's all over the media. I can't play
all of them. You just do YouTube
congressional hearings UFOs. It's all
over mainstream media.
The people are interviewed in Congress.
And they're saying, "Yes,
they're real."
That's exactly, Manny. I've been saying
it. And I've said it not because I'm an
expert, because there have been experts
in the field, both Christian and not
Christian, who have been saying they
exist and they're demons.
Experts in the field. Now, I think the
cat wants food, darn it. All right.
Okay, let me show you.
Okay, here you go.
My playlist.
And I want to play a few seconds. I
can't play all of it. So, if you go to
Well, you know, you can't go. You got to
be Yeah, all right.
You can't do the history.
Okay?
Yeah, you can see on my playlist I also
got Bruce Lee. All right, sue me cuz I
watch Bruce Lee. Okay, sue me.
Anyway, there's another I'm watching a
documentary on the Yahweh ben Yahweh
cult where this black guy claimed to be
Yahweh, the son of Yahweh, and it was a
murderous cult. He ended up in jail. But
forget it. Now, watch here.
Do you see that?
Three UFO
witnesses dropped out of hearing last
minute
because of potential threat.
That picture is from the actual con-
congressional
hearings. And those two were
whistleblowers. Now, let me play just
the beginning, all right? I'm going to
play a few.
Okay.
This cat needs attention. Remind me to
mention the Greg Stafford article, okay?
Love you, kitty. Now, watch.
When they say it can't be done,
>> Uh, shut up.
>> we say,
"Just watch us." out at the last minute
after receiving calls from the Pentagon.
That's according to Congressman Tim
Burchett. Here he is on NewsNation last
night. You thought there was going to be
about half a dozen witnesses, so six
witnesses. We ended up seeing the three
witnesses. Was there a plan to have
more? Yes. Absolutely. And um
Uh we had one tell us that that he'd
received a call from, I guess, uh maybe
the the Pentagon and and he decided, he
or she decided that maybe it wasn't best
that they were on there. We had somebody
who was in affiliation with NASA. NASA
will say, "Well, they didn't work for
NASA. This is not This is news to us."
But
it was one of their quasi uh something.
I don't know. See?
>> But anyway, and they they turned us they
backed out at the end and They backed
out. So, one guy got
word from, right? Government. Hey,
time for you to
pull out. But the other three were
interviewed. Now, some more clips.
Some more clips, all right? That was
one. I'm going to play a few more clips.
You know, I can't play all of it cuz I'm
going to get flagged. Hold on.
So now it's out out and about. It's
public, people.
Here's another one.
a subcommittee hearing about a possible
US government cover-up about contact it
has UFOs, but the classified nature of
what he knows prevented him from
elaborating or providing evidence to
back up his allegations. Congressman
Jared Moskowitz told reporters that the
committee is planning a workaround where
Grusch can finally reveal what he knows.
Let's watch.
>> Okay, anyway, I can't play too much, but
do it. Congressional hearings UFOs. So
that was the second one.
Okay, that was the second one.
Okay, now let me go to the third one.
Okay, guys, I can't play too much.
We're living in exciting times. If now
they're coming public, Jesus is closer
in his return than ever before. We may
be that generation. Not saying thus
saith the Lord, but if we live to be 70,
like if I have 23 more years, I won't be
shocked if the Lord Jesus returns within
20-30 years. We're that close, brethren.
It's happening. But I'm going to tell
you some dangerous things what this
implies.
Okay, here's another one.
unidentified anomalous phenomena this
week, and her testimony about object
sightings and government possession of
non-human material. One notable moment
from the hearing was when whistleblower
David Grusch said the United States
government is absolutely in possession
of UAPs.
>> See? UAPs.
>> Mr. Grusch, finally, do you believe that
our government is in possession of UAPs?
Uh absolutely based on interviewing over
40 witnesses over 4 years. And and
where?
I know the exact locations, and and
those locations were provided to the
Inspector General.
Do you catch it?
>> Grusch also said
>> Absolutely, over 40 witnesses, and I
know the location and where they have
the UFOs, the objects. See? Give me a
second, guys. I got to feed the cat.
You see, guys?
You're living in some mind-blowing
times. That's why knowledge is
exploding. Do you know why knowledge is
exploding, brethren?
You know why?
Because Jesus wants to give mankind a
last chance if he's coming in our
lifetime. If I'm wrong, Lord have mercy.
In his love, he will flood you with
information overload so you have no
doubt Jesus is Lord and he's real and be
prepared.
This is why the information is exploding
like never before cuz the Lord loves us
and wants to give us all the evidence to
know to trust in him. Glory be his name.
He will not leave us without a witness.
Hold on. Cat needs to go out.
Okay, don't be afraid of thunder.
You understand? This is why you're
seeing now an explosion, brethren.
An explosion of people returning to the
ancient churches.
Never before have you had such an
explosion of people running back to the
ancient churches.
Thank you, brother. Can you pray for my
discipline? God has given me the joy of
hitting weights again and glory to God,
my muscle memory is kicking in and I'm
getting my muscles in. Pray I'm not vain
about it, but stay healthy and fit and
use it to glorify Jesus Christ.